these are the new frontlines in the
fight against al-shabaab in Somalia and
these are the men taking that fight to
the armed group strongholds the United
States has at least 500 soldiers in this
country but it's trained and paid for
Somali troops to form the Deneb unit or
lightning force
apart from our operations against
al-shabaab fighters to retake
territories under their control we also
target their assassins
bomb builders and those who kidnap
foreigners in our country we also try to
arrest their spies in those who provide
them with arms and other supplies Somali
government officials say this elite
force is comprised of soldiers from
almost all of Somalia's clans Deneb
units have killed some of all Shabaab
senior leaders and in areas they have
retaken from the Al qaeda-linked group
they are winning the support of local
people how they would accent Holub
things are much better than before in
terms of security we're not living in
fear anymore these soldiers are God sent
you're forever thankful to the
government the Deneb brigade was
launched as a 150 person unit roughly
five years ago but as he has grown to
become one of Somalia's most used
military forces
well US forces in Somalia carry out
airstrikes and drone attacks against
al-shabaab fighters it's these forces
who've been carrying out the bulk of the
ground assault against the group
officials say the plan is to develop
then up into a force of 3,000 soldiers
capable of removing al-shabaab fighters
from towns and villages across the
country the regular Somali National Army
is involved in the fighting - the
advocate of an organic we have achieved
many victories we spent a lot of time
preparing for the current offensive
against al-shabaab but it was worth the
wait we have liberated many towns and
villages in the past months the Somali
National Army needs more recruits to
bolster its rungs this training camp in
the small town of guru Allen Central
Somalia is just one of a few across the
country by next year 22,000 African
Union peacekeepers I expected to begin
bring out of Somalia and it will fall to
these soldiers to take over the task of
keeping security and fighting al-shabaab
Mohammed Al Jazeera
guru L in central Somali